i'm curious because and this is i'd like
to pick your brain
the campaign strategist part of your
brain
if you're on trump's team you must be
thinking right now about all the missed
opportunities because as you said
we both know historically the incumbent
is
has a huge advantage and also in this
area in a crisis and yes and then uh so
number one there's uh kovid
pretty much i mean trump himself said it
he said i'm a wartime president
he could have been a wartime president
if he had said
i take this really seriously and here's
what we need to do
yeah he would have had the approval of
so many
people on the left suddenly and
then you look at picking an unnecessary
fight
with the ghost of john mccain in arizona
and the list goes on and on and on
of the things that he did that i'm sure
his strategist must have been pulling
their hair out
because when you look at the results now
i know a lot of
um democrats are maybe disappointed that
this
is this close and they think how could
it be this close well
uh it on the republican side
they must be thinking this was very
winnable he could have had this
that is exactly the conversation they're
having not just on the broader
republican side but inside
trump's own circle that and and he
didn't need to do everything different
with covet he needed to do
it like ten percent better he needed to
figure out
how it and and someone said this to me
on the saturday before the election
that if he loses it will be because
he could never be convinced that
actually doing the right
thing for the country would have been
good politics for him
he just couldn't be convinced of that
people try
um he he also has you know i mean
i don't know jared kushner so i don't
say this with any personal venom
but he is in so far over his head
he he is running the united states
government all of it
and he ran the presidential campaign
and again this is misreading mandates
because trump won four years ago jared
thought he was really good at both those
things
he sucks about those things you know the
country was just primed for sort of this
radical disruption
of our you know sort of status quo in
our politics and
and trump wrote in and excited and
titillated people
but the notion that they were going to
be able to do things better than tony
fauci
and that they were going to and it
transcended into everything they knew
more about the pandemic than tony fauci
they knew more about
campaigning for president than you know
chris christie or the people
around them that have done it before if
he loses it won't be because
people didn't want him to succeed they
they did desperately and if you said
if he had done a decent job on covet
it's not clear that there is a home run
to be hit but he couldn't even pretend
to care yeah about the way people are
living
in this time of the pandemic